remettre les choses à plat pour éviter
ce genre de scène voilà l'objectif
premier de ce nouveau de la sécurité en
pleine polémique sur les violences
policières
emmanuel macron veut drastiquement
changé les choses afin d'améliorer les
conditions d'exercice des forces de
l'ordre et consolider leurs liens avec
les français une idée loin de satisfaire
l'opposition mais moi j'aimerais bien
que le président la république est enfin
en matière de sécurité
une idée claire de la façon dont il faut
mobiliser des moyens avoir une vision
pour la sécurité pour là pour protéger
les français
et puis une stratégie je vois rien de
tout ça alors on peut appeler ça le
bourg de la sécurité mais si c'est pour
demain lâcher les forces de l'ordre
comme le président de la république le
fait un jour sur deux puis revenir en
arrière puis re proposer quelque chose
tout ça tourne à vide ça fait trois ans
et demi que ça tourne à vide ça fait
trois ans indique les français sont pas
protégés moi j'étais allé en prison qu'à
chaque fois que le chef de l'état et
dont un problème il a tendance à
inventer un truc un comité théodule
fait surtout pour gagner du temps et
donc au général il ne prend aucun au
plus conséquence des choses qui ont été
proposées dans ces comités 7 est vrai
que le grand débat ça a été vrai avec
eux
le conseil le comité citoyen sur la
glycation l'environnement lui climatique
et là j'ai un peu peur que ce soit la
même chose le chef de l'état prendra
part personnellement à ce grenelle de la
police qui réunira en janvier des
représentants des forces de l'ordre
des élus et des citoyens une initiative
en réponse aux nombreuses critiques
adressées par les syndicats de police à
la suite de l'interview donnée par
emmanuel macron aux médias brut la
semaine dernière et notamment sur le
contrôle au faciès
malgré mes mes engagements je suis
obligé de le constater parce qu'on a
quand j'écoute les jeunes moins jeunes
en tout cas toutes celles et ceux qui
ont une bonne raison d'être discriminés
parce qu'ils sont maghrébine maghrébins
ou d'origine maghrébine parce qu'ils
sont noirs parce que voilà leur couleur
de peau le radio le quartier fait que
tout est prédisposé ils se sentent
discriminés et donc ça commence comme ça
et en effet à ce moment là la haine de
la police commence là et les quelques
chiffres dont on dispose ils disent des
mots qui ont déclenché la colère des
policiers plusieurs actions dont l'arrêt
des contrôles d'identité se sont
déroulées à travers la capitale pour
dénoncer ces propos une interwiew qui a
laissé des traces au sein des forces de
l'ordre
même si votre discours venait dans sa
globalité souligné l'action des forces
de l'ordre et des policiers mes
collègues retiennent une seule chose à
savoir que les contrôles au faciès
existent qui sont une réalité qu'un
jeune homme de couleur à plus de chances
d'être contrôlés que les autres
personnes cette affirmation est venu
remettre en cause la qualité du travail
quotidien des forces de l'ordre et
particulièrement celui des policiers
nationaux surtout ceux engagés dans les
quartiers difficiles
au centre des discussions de ce bourreau
de la sécurité formation encadrement
moyens captations vidéos des
interventions inspection effectifs et
lien entre la police et population
en clair les sept chantiers annoncés par
le ministre de l'intérieur
par ailleurs 1,5 milliard d'euros de
crédits budgétaires supplémentaires
pourraient être débloqués l'issue de
cette réunion
salué par les syndicats mais insuffisant
pour eux ce type de réunion ne permet
pas de régler les problèmes
le syndicat rayons
ça d'ailleurs prévenu qu'il ne
répondrait pas à l'invitation présidence